[Music]
kyle carpenter
is the youngest living recipient of the
congressional medal of honor
the highest medal in the land i'll read
from his citation
on november 21 2010 21 year old lance
corporal carpenter
and a fellow marine were manning a
rooftop security position
on the perimeter of patrol-based dakota
in afghanistan
when the enemy initiated a daylight
attack with hand grenades
one of which landed inside their
sandbagged position
without hesitation and with complete
disregard for his own safety
lance corporal carpenter moved toward
the grenade in an attempt to shield his
fellow marine
from the deadly blast when the grenade
detonated
his body absorbed the brunt of the blast
severely wounding him but saving the
life
of his fellow marine kyle talks about
the responsibility he feels to wear the
title of marine
to being a recipient of the medal of
honor and most of all
the awesome responsibility we all have
to our fellow human beings this
is a bit of optimism
[Music]
the funny thing is i was going to ask
you can you tell your story
but it occurred to me that i probably
know as much about your story as you do
because you don't really remember what
happened but you remember before and you
remember after is that
true that is correct yes can you tell me
you were 20 21 years old i just turned
21.
been in the marine corps not even two
years yet right correct not even two
years
can you lead me up to what you remember
absolutely
so just for a little context a lot of
people want to know you know what the
four months like was leading up to that
from sun up to sundown every single day
was a constant and
violent fight for survival
and every single night i lay my head
down
on the dirt and i think everyone
if you really think about things while
you're over there you can't help but to
think
and wonder is this the last time i'm
going to lay my head down on my pillow
and as violent and scary and uncertain
as it was
i believed it then and i believe it just
as much if not more today
that you know whatever the big
convoluted political reasons are
for things we were there simply
trying to help our fellow struggling
human beings
and so in a way i was kind of at peace
and kind of content with
if it is the last time i'll lay my head
down on my pillow
um i'm okay with that and so uh that
that's just a little context as to how
the deployment was
fast forward to november 21st
this is 2010 and my squad and i
got tasked with pushing south
and moving into a new village taking
over a new compound
and essentially just try to survive and
keep your foot in the ground until we
can get you reinforcements
and we started getting shot at about
halfway down so that was a great start
to the mission
we take over the compound and very
shortly after
the first hand grenade attack came and
whether it was hand grenades or small
arms fire the attacks were pretty
consistent
over the next 24 to 30 hours until the
the day and afternoon that i got hit
i got hit on november 21st and the only
thing i remember from that entire day
was surprise surprise we started getting
attacked that morning around sunrise
and i remember it was about 7 30 going
on 8 a.m
and i hear the the ak-47s
and i remember rolling over and
unzipping my sleeping bag
and thinking something like here we go
again in another day in afghanistan
fast forward to later that afternoon
and the only other thing i remember from
that entire day
was right before
i got hit myself and
a fellow marine and best friend nicki
frazio
he was my point man in my squad we did
every patrol together
just an incredible person in marine we
were on
post together anyone listening not
familiar with military terminology
it's just a lookout position it's a high
elevated position
to look outside of the base for enemy
activity to keep those
inside the base that aren't on watch and
vigilant
safe we had made it almost entire four
hours
of our shift time our relief was getting
geared up was about to climb up on the
roof to us
and uh nick and i were going through
scenarios
just to try to get even if it was a half
of a second
uh a jump on a reaction of
anything that would happen hey if they
attack from this road
or this alleyway this is how what you'll
do this is what i'll do this is how
we'll respond
and ironically the very last thing that
i remember is asking nick what happens
when a grenade comes up here
and that was serious but also half
joking half dark humor just to get us
through
that eerily quiet and scary time
and he said my ass is off this roof
i said dude i'm right behind you clearly
our planning didn't work at all
but uh the next thing i remember
is i felt like i got hit really hard in
the face
my ears were immediately
ringing extremely loud just as they are
this very second as i'm talking to you
my vision was as if i was looking at a
tv with no connection
just white and gray static
and there was just an extreme sense of
confusion and disorientation
trying to put the pieces together i
thought okay well i'm pretty sure i was
in afghanistan
i'm pretty sure i was on a roof but what
could have possibly
injured me this bad on a roof because i
can't bury ieds and ruse and
uh i thought okay well maybe i got off
to the roof i went on a foot patrol and
i stepped on an ied
and that's just the last thing my mind
can can recollect
that was interrupted by and this next
part will allude to
marines humor with each other uh and
keep in mind i was very confused but
i felt like someone was pouring warm
water all over me
i'm thinking man guys come on it's kind
of messed up in this banged up state i'm
in
you know you're all messing with me
right now
but that final piece allowed all the
other
disoriented ones to fall into place and
i realized that
it wasn't warm water that i was
profusely bleeding out
and kind of with that piece of info just
how i
physically felt how quickly i was
getting tired and attired that
i can't even describe one that just
consumed every
fiber of my being
with that and then with unfortunately
the casualties i had seen so far on that
deployment
with blood boss and injuries and things
like that i knew
unfortunately that my time was coming to
a close
on this earth and with the last few
seconds i had i thought about my family
i thought about my mom and how
devastated she was going to be
when she found out that i was not
going to make it home alive and i said a
quick prayer
for forgiveness for anything i had done
wrong in my life
and i faded from consciousness in the
world on that hot dusty rooftop
and i to my very pleasant uh
surprise i woke up roughly five weeks
later
with snow outside of my hospital room
window
on the other side of the world in
washington dc
at walter reed national military medical
center
and uh i opened you know the only i had
left
and my first sight to this new world
and beautiful bonus round that i'm
living now
was red christmas stockings that my mom
had hung
decorating my room for christmas you
know that
was the start
of this at times very difficult
but overall extremely beautiful journey
that i've been on these past as crazy as
it sounds 11 years now
thank you you're welcome you use words
that i think a lot of people
would not expect to hear when you tell
your story
you use the word beautiful journey can
you just unpack that for me please
there were many long dark and painful
nights but
i think pain is a gift
i guess the best way to summarize it is
all of
the hardships have not just made me
better
but it's taught me
perspective it can never be stated how
important perspective
is it's just taught me so many lessons
that
i'm thankful that you know a lot of
people don't use words like that when it
comes to hardships
because you know i was pushed to
such a limit to be resuscitated three
times to wake up and be told you have
three years and 40 surgeries minimum
left in this hospital
all that is very difficult but it's
taught me
through those dark times to find the
silver linings
it's taught me to look at the glass
half full but also remember
you know what it was like when i looked
at it half empty
and ultimately that grenade gave me
you know i would say and i'm still
trying to discover it
and still trying to understand it but
that grenade gave me
a profound insight to where
i can now take what i've been through
and help
other people through their own struggles
to tell people that
even the smallest of steps eventually
completes the grandest of journeys
that you can actually get knocked down
in life
and come back better and stronger than
you were before
also i've learned that struggle
and hardship is the bridge
and common thread throughout every
single person on this earth
you know i've been through what i've
been through you've been through what
you've been through
we all can say that but yet we all
heal in our own time in our own ways
it's hard to summarize
all the amazing and powerful and
profound lessons that
i have learned and experienced through
all of this
but i hope i summarized it enough
right there you're so present
right now it's not lost on me that you
are asked to talk about this a lot
you know whether it's public speeches or
meeting people
and yet here i am
and i'm just profoundly moved by how
present you are as you tell your story
slowly and steadily and conscientiously
as if you're telling me for the first
time when you talk about learning
lessons
what i see what i hear is
someone who's listening to their own
words constantly learning more each time
you talk about it about yourself
were you like this as a young man as a
young marine were you
introspective and were you that friend
you know who gave us perspective or did
this come afterwards
i think internally i was like that to
some degree i don't think i was the guy
that everyone was coming to like dr
phil but uh three years
uh in the hospital is you know it can be
seen in the
in the big picture as not that long or a
very long time
but with that time with the hours i was
in pre-op before every surgery
with the hours i sat in therapy
wondering if
my finger or my hand was going to ever
twitch or make that nerve graft
connection again
you know going through that but then
also getting out of the hospital
and immediately starting college
getting into public speaking and
realizing that
i had a platform i guess you could say
but put the platform aside and just the
intimate everyday conversations with
people
i did have to realize that it is the
first time
they might be talking to me or listening
to what i'm saying
it might be the first time they're
talking to a marine
a veteran a injured and combat wounded
warrior
it might be the first time they're
talking to an american and of course
when the medal happened
i mean that just put an entire
new weight on things i
have to realize that i can be a bridge
and i can educate on you know it might
not be perfect
but maybe how to get through your own
struggle
your life profoundly changed surviving
your your injuries
did it change a second time when you
were awarded the medal of honor because
you just said a second ago
the responsibility that came with that
medal what did you mean by that
well i'm happy to report that uh
you know i don't feel one percent
different
from the moment i became melavon
recipient to
the second before when i was kyle back
on the block
you know i just i'm very thankful that
i've just always felt like me and that
the medal is just
a tremendous honor but what's changed is
my sense of continued duty
and the level of responsibility that i
feel
what responsibility do you feel well
when the president draped the mail
around my neck
it was heavy i mean it was a heavy
moment
i always knew that it was never mine
or it was never one individual's it
never has been it never will be
but i realize that that medal of honor
does not just represent myself
it represents the journey that
the marines that had their boots in the
dirt in afghanistan
endured with me and us together
it represents my family and
the long terrifying dark nights in the
icu for
weeks where they just hoped that i would
take that next breath
my brothers who spent their christmas
and a year of middle school living
and visiting my hospital room it
represents
the children in afghanistan that ask me
through interpreters is everywhere in
america like disney world
can you really turn a knob in your house
and get fresh clean drinking water
it represents all of the people around
the world
that for whatever reason they wake up
and they hope
that today's sunrise is going to be a
little better than the day before
you go beyond that and it represents not
only those
that didn't make it back because they
gave
their last full measure of devotion in a
field of a distant land that
most people probably won't even be able
to point out on a map
but it represents those souls that are
still guarded today at the tomb of the
unknown soldier
we can't even tell their families
where they took that last breath how
they took it how they were injured
and so it's just it's a beautiful burden
and it's extremely heavy but one that
i will forever be extremely grateful and
humbled
and honored to
to carry and i'm also very thankful that
my country recognized me because
you know that not only doesn't happen
that much for whatever reason in today's
military
but just the fact that i could be
recognized
and really be given a tool that led to a
platform
to where i can again educate but more
specifically
share everything i just did and
their journeys obviously they don't have
a voice anymore so
there's a lot that comes with it but i
just hope that
you know like on the roof i can be the
marine and friend and melanie recipient
that
you know i need to be i talk about my
interest in exaggerated cases because it
really helps
see the point and i think a lot of
people misunderstand the military and
definitely misunderstand marines
and i've had the opportunity to spend
time with some marines and
and i've been to paris i'm sorry i want
to go i'm sorry
i know i know it's okay the therapy's
working
and when i i had the chance to ask
maureen you know
what makes the marines so good and he
said
love love of country love of core
love of your fellow marine and you speak
like someone who's in love you threw
yourself in between a
grenade and your friend they don't train
you to do that
they train you to do all kinds of things
but that's not one of the things they
train for
yeah i don't recommend it
you know that that behavior that
instinct
because remember the two of you joked
and planned
that if that happens you're gonna jump
off the roof and yet you did the
complete opposite
can't follow a plan not not my best
decision
but i mean it's too hard to ask you
now because it's instinct you sort of
what
inspired or motivated you to do that uh
well you're right
uh i love nick and i love the marines
that i was with
and i love the marine corps and i will
you know however my journey turned out i
will
forever love the marine corps and be so
appreciative
of them allowing me to join and to serve
because it it gave me a a portal
and an opportunity to what i feel like
reach my destiny and to
be able to fulfill my purpose
and i don't know exactly what that is
but i know because of what i've been
through
it couldn't have been any other way i
want to unpack this for people who don't
know the military which is the real
cynics out there
will hear some of your words and say
brainwash
right because that's what the military
does they brainwash these kids
right yeah and what what we're missing
here is
you said i love nick now you're a
warrior
you're a combat veteran and a warrior
and you say
i love nick those are the words you use
and i love the marines
that i served with you didn't
necessarily like them all but you love
them all
right yeah and we who go to work in the
private sector
civilians rarely if ever
will say of our colleagues i love them
and if you feel it you really don't say
it in fact a lot of people are
uncomfortable even saying
i love you to our friends
and i think it's very important for
people to understand
that it is really this shared struggle
and shared hardship
that this group of people endure that we
know biologically shared struggle and
shared hardship brings people together
you know you go to
to a place where there's a hurricane or
a tornado all of a sudden politics don't
matter
none of that stupid stuff that we argue
about matters all of a sudden
we come together and we take care of
each other and we hug each other
and we cry with each other and people
will talk about the fact that they will
risk their lives
for their children because they love
their children it's this it's they will
risk their lives but for their spouse
because they love their spouse
and love makes us do crazy things
that put ourselves in harm's way for
someone else and it's love
that motivates this instinct because
there was no thinking there was no time
to think
you didn't weigh the pros and the cons
and you have to have an intense
relationship with someone
or an intense relationship with your
cause for the instinct to be i'm going
to put myself in harm's way to save the
life of another human being
you know to answer your question and i
have thought about this a lot
i love nick and my fellow marines but
rewind a little bit and from the moment
that van door is seemingly ripped off
its hinges
by the scariest human being i've ever
seen in my life and you get out of that
van
and you're getting screamed at and
you're told you're talking about
you're talking about boot camp yeah when
you get when you get
told to stand on those yellow footprints
at paris island
from that moment on over the next 13
weeks of boot camp in your career
every day through training when you're
the most beat down
which is every minute you're there
you're correct you are not
trained to jump on a grenade i don't
even think you could train that
if you wanted to i don't think you could
yeah but what
you are taught is all of the generations
and courageous stories of those
who wore the same uniform that you were
about to put on
just unfathomable stories
of the 17 18 19 year olds
that they were told you're probably not
even gonna make it onto the beach
in world war ii at normandy throughout
the pacific
you know uh where the marines were
you're probably not even going to make
it out of a landing craft
if you do you're probably not going to
survive
charging the beach and if you do
you know you're in the 10 to 20 percent
and knowing that they still charge for
it anyway
the marines that covered grenades for
their fellow marines
who bled out in the fields of vietnam
you know the marines that i saw in
afghanistan that took a knee in front of
the locals during firefights hoping that
if a round came in
they would take it instead of the the
father and son
you're trained through incredible
stories and through our incredible
history
of marines that came before us so when
the time comes whether it's to
charge into a firefight or onto a beach
or take a grenade
you want to be courageous because you
know
the boots and the uniform that you're
filling this is a really important point
which is so many people we hear this
from politicians all the time which is
they invoke the future
they invoke our children we have to do
this for the future we have to do this
for the children for this abstract
unwritten future and if that was truly
our motivation we wouldn't make half the
decisions we make
right but the reality is the past is
not unwritten the past happened and the
past is not ethereal
it's tangible and we are more likely to
make
good decisions right decisions ethical
and moral decisions when we feel a
responsibility
as you said to those who came before us
to uphold and ensure that their
sacrifice does not go in vain
than to invoke the future absolutely
the past is i mean really all
we can learn from yeah and here you are
this marine who
the uniform you wear you carry
in this uniform the stories of vietnam
and korea
and world war ii and all of the
heroism and sacrifice it was all wrapped
up in that eagle globe and anchor
that when you say i'm a marine you're a
part of a club that includes all of
those brave men and women
and now you are a part of that legacy
and all the future marines
now wear the uniform of which includes
your story and
those of your fellow marines and i find
this idea of knowing that you're a part
of a continuum
that your life is simply a moment in a
very very big story humbling
but i think it conveys that sense of
awesome responsibility
as you said the congressional medal of
honor is not yours it does not belong to
you
but rather others have worn it and
others will wear it
and you are a part of a member of
and that membership comes with
responsibility
but it's not mine right
and i think it's very specific you know
a lot of and you know this
civilians will say you won the medal
and for folks who haven't served in the
military if you listen carefully
folks in the middle of say i was awarded
a medal or she was awarded a medal but
then they said
one and i think this is a really
sophisticated and something that i have
learned from
the folks that i've had the the honor to
call friends
from the military and you said it before
which is language
has power yes and our ability to
to adapt our language will affect not
only how we view others and
but how we view ourselves and i think
one of the things you learn in the
military you learn these words you learn
love you learn honor
honor means something and you're in
where you come from honor
kind of is a cheesy thing that comes
from movies with knights and shining
armor
outside of your world which is why i
think it's important for
folks like you to tell your story
because folks like us
need to hear your story and need to
learn these new perspectives you called
your book you are worth it
and it's such an first of all it's a
good title because it's nuanced and
multifaceted
because you're referring to yourself but
you're also referring to other people
right
exactly i i'm sure you you had to
convince yourself that you were worth it
to go through the struggle that you went
through for those three years in
hospital
i did and i
i didn't think of it like that i
thought of it as i thought of it as
the inside and that that was a good one
i was a curveball never been hit with
i thought about it as my own
personal challenge and journey
to prove to myself the lesson i said at
the beginning of this and that is
that not one no matter what you go
through
you can get through it whether it takes
a day or the rest of your life
you can't first of all but then the
follow-on to that was
how can i come back better and stronger
than i was before i got
knocked down or blown up
details details right right
and so and this really started very
early on
and i again i woke up i had one eye
eardrums were blown out
and the only thing that wasn't injured
on me was my left ankle which is what my
parents held on to for 24 hours a day
until i got out of
the icu hallucination stage of things
and here i am all banged up my arms are
tied up to this like crazy bed
contraption for swelling
because my arms were getting so swollen
that they were having to cut them open
because they were so swollen that they
were cutting off the circulation to
wherever it was the most swollen
anything below that
and uh the worst part or
maybe or top three of my time in the
hospital
and those first three months was having
a trach
and breathing through a tiny straw in my
neck
when you're under intense pain what do
you do
try to breathe you try to get through it
and
you know i was first of all i'm kind of
claustrophobic
uh and so by the time i slowly
sucked in enough air i was already
panicked to kind of get it back out
and so there were just all these things
but through all of
these things and don't ask me how i had
this thought or this insight
probably half medication thinking i
could even
possibly do this later on but i had that
thought
you know what can i do to to
somehow prove to just to myself i didn't
tell anyone this
and myself alone to show that hey
i'm not just still with it and i'm not
just still kyle
but i'm a better version yeah and i
thought
maybe one day i can attempt to marathon
because i had never done
i mean i thought about it but i had
never attempted or taken the idea of a
marathon seriously before i was injured
you know fast forward through again many
long dark and painful nights and
slow progress and i realized that
well if i can sit up in the bed which
was a very difficult task because when
your body's
unconscious and atrophying for over a
month
you know everything from your muscles to
your bones to
your breathing you know has to kind of
get
back in gear so i'll get extremely
nauseous anytime i even tried to sit up
so we did the whole okay well we'll give
him a shot of zofran 30 minutes before
he wants to move
uh you know we'll get the bed pan out so
he can take care of that
and then we'll try to try to get him
going okay
but i realized that so of course the
logical thing is to think i'd love to do
a marathon
it makes perfect sense kyle perfect
sense
i said i was heavily medicated simon
but uh i realize though if i can sit up
in the bed
i can work on hanging my feet off the
edge yeah
if i can hang my feet off the edge i can
work on standing
if i can stand i can take a step
if i can take a step i can walk if i can
walk
maybe one day i can run and attempt that
marathon
and so now today i've
crossed the finish line of that marathon
three times
and the first time i did it which was
and i don't recommend this either but it
was just a few months after i got out of
hospital
and i was working on the freshman 15
from
from usc so i just was this is not the
best time to attend the marathon
and i didn't train for it so i just
because i was i was over three on
on going into this uh
but when i crossed that finish line i'm
thankful i had sunglasses
on because i immediately teared up yeah
i just got so emotional because in that
moment i
deep down truly
wholeheartedly not just believe
but now i knew
that all of the things i have been
trying to teach myself
and all of the silver linings and the
small lessons and
the smallest steps hopefully completes
the grandest of journeys type mindset
the moment my foot crossed that finish
line
it went from belief and hope
to true and 50
of my emotion was that i proved it to
myself
but the other 50 was
i almost crossed the finish line
completing
that difficult chapter for my family
there's a piece to this that was really
important for us to talk about
which is there's two meetings to you or
worth it
one is to say it to yourself that for me
to push myself
to learn resilience to learn grit to
endure
is because i am worth it i'm a work in
progress and i am worth it
and the other reason is because you're
doing it for others
and the sacrifices that we make are for
others because they are worth it
they are worth our sacrifice whether
it's the the legacy of the past
or the people in our lives now
yes and this is the reality of being
human which is we have to contend with
being an individual
and we have to contend with being a
member of a group every day exactly
and our nation and we're not going to go
down this rabbit hole
i believe has over-indexed on rugged
individualism
it's over indexed on the marlborough man
and putting ourselves first i i often
joke that there's an entire section in
the bookshop called self-help and
there's no section in the bookshop
called help others
yeah wow so true and what we need is a
help others industry
and that's the second application of you
are worth it
which is i will struggle because i am
worth it and i think we
have learned all these positive
reinforcements and these
self-affirmations because that's what
we're being told but it doesn't quite
work
until you have someone in your life that
you love
so deeply that you will struggle and
sacrifice
because they are worth it and that
dual meaning that nuance of you are
worth it is both for us as individuals
but
also for the people in our lives why did
you do that why did you
throw yourself in front of a grenade why
did you run the marathon
why did you you know push through to
become a better version of yourself
it's not all for you it continues to be
in service to the people
you love and even some of the people you
love that you don't know
you talked about it a few times your
fellow human beings absolutely
and i know this about you and you know
this there's a weird controversy in the
military
how folks in uniform feel when they're
in uniform and somebody comes up to them
that says thank you for your service
and some folks are fine with it they're
grateful and they say you're welcome
and some folks really hate it they get
really angry
when somebody comes up to them and says
thank you for your service it's a debate
what i think is interesting is your
answer that when somebody comes up to
you and says thank you for your service
you say
you are worth it that makes me cry
well it helps me to let them know that
you know whether it's someone on the
street here in charlotte north carolina
or where the title and
kind of this phrase really came to
prominence is
talking to my uber driver shout out
bobby from pakistan
uh he was taking me to the airport 10
minutes down the road
and um you know he said a bunch of
beautiful things to me about my service
and he thanked me
and i said you are worth it and it was
the first time i had really said it and
i
you know me now i had to go and think
about it and dissect it in the airport
and um you know i realized and
everything you said was beautifully put
i really don't even have to add anything
because you really
said it perfectly i
had to feel like my you know first of
all life is worth it
and i had to feel like my struggle and
my purpose
and my life was worth fighting for
it was worth carrying on it was worth
staying
i had to work and learn and understand
that side of it
but you know whether i was saying you
are worth
it to bobby or someone here
you know on the sidewalk in a way
it is kind of putting it back on them
and making them think you know wow like
this guy's obviously got very injured
had a hard road and he's saying i'm
worth it
so i hope to make people think you know
what have i done or what should i do
or how can i start giving back yeah
so i can feel like i'm worth him telling
me that
but ultimately above you know even that
it's to to let people know exactly that
that they are
worth serving for they are worth
sacrificing for
and they are worth time in a hospital
bed and
deep scars on my body because
and you made the the comment earlier
about
how you know we love each other because
in the marines we have this common
mission and common goal and
really take the military out of it and
we're all in this strange and
challenging journey of life together
no matter your background or your walk
of life now
to help someone to be there for someone
to tell someone you care
is very special and very powerful and
you know those few seconds leading up to
the grenade on the roof
of course the questions have always been
there what were you thinking why'd you
do it
of course i don't remember and i just
realized this in the past few years but
i think
that people being in such disbelief and
wondering
so intently how i did that
is the greatest and kind of
most ironic thing of all because that's
the beauty of the human spirit
yeah you never know how when
or to what capacity you're going to step
up
and not just be a hero
but be a life-saving hero for someone
whether that's laying on a grenade on
top of a roof on the other side of the
world
or putting your arm around someone and
saying hey
this is obviously bad but it's not
really that bad you can get through it
and if you need someone to get through
with you let me know and and i'm there
yeah i mean that is i think i think
people don't realize
just how profound that is and it's the
same question
right when somebody asks you why did you
throw yourself on a grenade to protect
your fellow marine
when i showed up to work late because my
friend was having a hard time and i put
my arm around them and said
you got this and i'm there for you and
they turn to me and say
why would you say that why are you doing
that why are you missing work
why are you sacrificing for me the
answer's the same
it's because you're worth it
and what a powerful thing to be that
person to someone else right
because one day they're gonna need
want and hope
when the time comes that you know you'll
need that conversation
and now the roles reversed yeah you made
it your mission to become a better
version of yourself
and uh i have no idea what you were like
before but you're
a remarkable version of yourself today
and and i hope people take your lessons
to heart and practice your philosophy
the world would be a lot better place if
we all
saw the world and the way you see it
kyle thank you so much thank you simon i
appreciate that
this opportunity and i look forward to
uh
many years of a friendship to come it's
an honor
thank you
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other
you